deuxième objectif
devenir le leader de l'hydrogène vert en
2030 là je le dis en l'assumant
totalement je pense ça fait partie
vraiment dans des secteurs où nous
pouvons être leader c'est une vraiment
une filière dans l'énergie où nous
pouvons encore le faire parce que nous
avons des atouts on a un premier atout
c'est encore une fois le nucléaire
pour produire de l'hydrogène il faut
l'électricité parce qu'il faut faire de
l'électoralisme et beaucoup de d'élèves
que d'ingénieurs donc j'ai l'impression
de dire des gens qui savent beaucoup
mieux que moi comment ça marche mais je
le dis pour nom pour ce soit clair parce
que sinon on perd de vue de nos débats
donc on a besoin de faire de l'
électrolyse sa consomment beaucoup
d'électricité si on produit de
l'hydrogène
en utilisant du d'énergie fossile ça
sert à rien
on peut produire on va produire de
l'hydrogène en important des
renouvelables mais aujourd'hui compte
tenu de l'électrification des mobilités
que l'europe de toute façon à décider
pour elles mêmes il n'est pas vrai qu'on
aura une énorme produits qu'on n'aura
jamais en europe suffisamment de
production de renouvelables pour faire
nos grandes électrolyse et produire de
l'hydrogène vert et donc il ya en fait
deux grandes stratégies de production
d'hydrogène vers ya une stratégie qui
consiste à aller faire les e mails les
énergies non renouvelables pardon pour
faire lé électrolyse très loin et
réimporter l'hydrogène ainsi produite un
peu comme on fait avec le gaz
notifié il ya une deuxième stratégie qui
va être le coeur de la nôtre nous on
fera les 2 qui va être de d'essayer d'en
produire beaucoup chez nous parce que on
a la possibilité de faire de l'électro
lis très décarbonés et donc ça c'est une
énorme chance c'est ce qui nous
permettra d'être en leader à côté de ça
on a de la très bonne recherche on a des
très bons acteurs air liquide et
quelques autres industriels et on a un
tissu de start-up d'équipementiers
d'entrepreneurs d'innovateur qui sont
prêts à y aller et sont organisés et
donc ce que nous devons faire absolument
sur l'hydrogène c'est ne pas répéter les
erreurs que nous avons faites sur les
énergies renouvelables on a trop peu
investi sur l'offre et la capacité à
développer notre filière on l'a laissé
filer ailleurs on doit développer notre
offre industrielle dans l'hydrogène et
donc investir massivement dans cette
filière et donc tout ça nous permettra
de décarbonés notre industrie
d'alimenter nos camions autobus nos
trains nos avions
et une voix absolument formidable ce qui
fait que d'ici à 2030 la france doit
pouvoir compter sur son sol au moins
deux gigas factory d'électrolyseurs et
produira massivement de l'hydrogène et
l'ensemble des technologies utiles à son
utilisation
en parallèle de cette deuxième grand
objectif
nous aurons aussi un objectif
d'investissement de plus de 500 millions
d'euros dans les technologies de rupture
dans les énergies non renouvelables
particulier éoliennes terrestres et en
mer et photovoltaïque parce que la
stratégie d'investissement dans les
énergies non renouvelables est un point
clé pour l'innovation de rupture c'est
ce triptyque si vous voulez nucléaire
hydrogène
et énergie non renouvelable par ses
innovations de rupture qui nous
permettra de produire différemment de
l'énergie et d'électricité et de
commencer à contribuer justement un ce
monde où on produit mieux et plus dé
carbonée nous avons comme vous le voyez
des vrais leviers on a des vrais
avantages historiques mais il faut
accepter d'y mettre les investissements
que je viens d'évoquer pour être
atteindre ses objectifs
[Musique]